go for the most simple way how to win  this  making a trade keeping the king in the  corner and young christopher duda is  talking to his pieces yeah the hit still  game two going on for him against raj  above looks like a draw on the bar  yeah it's uh maybe a missed opportunity  yeah for youngsters of duda frustration  for him he wants to strike back  and uh it's just not gonna be in this  game for him unfortunately yeah and uh  we might see an arabian checkmate on the  board  that sounds really fancy it does sound  fancy so if black makes some random move  with the rook then the knight will put  itself diagonally opposite the king and  the king is trapped can't move and it's  called the arabian checkmate because  it's the oldest checkmate this is like  around and 700. so buyer diagonally you  mean the f6 square and yeah with that in  sight  with checkmate incoming anishigiri  resigns it's a comeback from levon  neronia and they are tied now at la  sierra